[Music]
sydney is in san diego hi sydney how are
you
dave how's it going
great how can we help
okay well first of all we love you
we're debt free
um and all because of you we just love
you so much um but we're wondering so
disneyland is back open
and
we're wondering if we if it's okay for
us to make monthly payments on our
disney passes just because we're
thinking
if
california shuts down again
will we be out of our money for the
passes
oh so you want to buy season passes to
disneyland
correct yeah they have a month they have
a monthly plan or an annual plan
yes and it's an interest-free plan
and it is so is the if you quit paying
the monthly does the pass just stop
correct
okay well that's just like you're buying
anything else then that's more of a
subscription than it is a debt
okay so i mean you can
stop by if you bought put cable tv in
your house and you decided you didn't
want anymore you stop doing it
right okay and you don't have the bill
anymore and that's what this is what's
the difference between the annual plan
and the monthly plan
um well the annual plan is 650 upfront
and then the monthly plan the monthly
plan is 40 a month for 12 months
so the monthly plan is cheaper by 200
that's you something's wrong
well it's i was i'm 40 40 times 12 is
480
480 is less than 650 they're charging
you less for the monthly plan
by oh you know what i think that you i'm
sorry i think that you also have to make
a down payment when you first sign up
for the plan the monthly plan okay
that's probably equal to the difference
yeah just just do the math because you
may find out that it's five months is
going to pay for the annual plan and i
understand not wanting to have them
holding your money
um if they have if california shuts down
again but yeah do the math on it yeah
make sure
you gotta have the other piece of this
what's the down payment if the down
payment's 400 now you got
880 bucks versus 650 that's not
interest-free darling
you
know it's just a different price plan
where they made you wish you'd paid
interest that's right